[Music]
in american reunion uh you uh you engage
in a little full-frontal nudity in this
film which is quite shocking i uh yeah
yeah yeah i do i do
was this uh well this is a brave
decision on your part i think the world
was just ready to see it frankly conan
but um
uh no it was kind of a kind of a crazy
thing you know i would and we did a lot
of work we put a lot of work into into
this scene making sure it looked right
we tried different positions different
o'clocks you know two o'clock you know 1
30. wait i don't have a minute hand so
that didn't work 130 wouldn't work but
yeah o'clock and all different you know
we would be anywhere from four to seven
o'clock i mean
spandy
way too much
it's the gumby of the penis world i can
it was like puppetry of the penis i did
one thing that was called the sydney
harbor bridge i did one thing called the
empire state building i did one thing
called the conan o'brien it was
fascinating
with the hair it was really yeah wow
it was great it was great this is funny
enough i tell you a minute just didn't
work
[Applause]
everyone settle down i'll clear this
area if i have to
i'll fill this room with foam
uh but yeah so we would you know we i
went to the editing room and would we
would talk to the directors about making
you know seeing seeing the footage and
and uh wait so you're really i'm being
honest here you're in an edit room
where they have hd monitors many of them
yeah and and you're looking at this part
of yourself yeah that uh and and and
you're talking about the lighting and
the and when the cup would have very
weird so we you end up taking it's very
serious work you're in there and we're
dissecting and we're looking we're like
well let's try this let's try that you
know do you have a shot of this and i
actually took a picture of the
paused uh footage because my wife was
very curious to know you know what it
was uh what the shot was going to going
to look like and so i took a picture for
her and then
took it home to show her this is funny
later that week my nephew was born and
i'm at the hospital taking pictures of
him and i'm loading up my phone with
with nephew pictures what a little
nugget he is conan and um
and then i'm in therapy about a week
later and i'm visiting with my female
therapist and i'm and i'm sitting down
and she knew i was about to have a
nephew and she said oh how how did you
know that i was like great i've got some
pictures would you like to see some
pictures
i've got them on my phone right here
here take a look i showed her my phone
and i'm like go ahead just scroll you're
scrolling i'm like looking over her
shoulder you know
just go ahead keep keep keep strolling
oh look at how cute he is there look at
how cute
i'm gonna take that and she
had a minute with my penis and then i
went and sat across back in the sofa and
i just kind of sat there and kind of
looked across at her and she kind of
looked at me and um
you know we kind of just tried
moving on from this subject and didn't
reference it for about a good minute and
a half and finally she's like
so how do you feel about me seeing your
penis about a minute ago
i said not so good i'll be honest with
you
it was it was all kind of uh of awkward
yeah so what's weird to me is that you
kept that picture on your phone you know
well i wasn't sure who else i was going
to have to show
yeah like the tsa or something yeah
you don't have to touch it it's right
here yeah yeah exactly
exactly